We're asked to prove
that triangle ADC is
congruent to triangle BEC, so
this left triangle's congruent
to this right triangle, and the
figure is not drawn to scale.
And we should never
assume that it is.
And then we have
some givens here.
So they tell us that segment
AC is congruent to BC.
So AC is congruent to BC.
And they also tell us that
CD is congruent to CE.
So CD is congruent to CE.
And I've got to mark it twice,
because CD is not necessarily
the right length as CA.
In fact, they don't
look anywhere close,
so we can't assume it.
But they tell us that
CD is congruent to CE.
So what else can we figure out
about this little diagram here
in order to be able to
say this left triangle's
congruent to the right?
Well, the one thing we know
is that this angle right
over here, angle ACD, is
congruent to angle BCE.
So let's write that down.
Angle ACD, and we don't have
to write the angle symbol.
And it's not easy to write
the angle symbol anyway,
it figures it out later
that we're actually
talking about an angle.
Angle ACD is congruent
to BCE, and we
can say that because
they're vertical angles.
Vertical angles are equal.
Fair enough.
And there you go, it added
the angle symbols for us.
And now, we can, I think,
well, that's enough information
to say that they are congruent.
We can now say that triangle ADC
is congruent to triangle BEC.
And we know that because we have
a side, an angle, and a side.
So by side-angle-side
congruence.
Sometimes it takes a
little bit of time,
it hangs up a little bit.
Luckily for me, this
time it did not do that.
And so I think I am done.
So let me check my answer here.
Drum roll.
And it worked.